Guten Morgen, Linus. Ich hoffe, du bist entspannt.
Guten Morgen, Tim. Total.
Lauschige Musik angemacht für dich, damit wir nach zwei Wochen Pause auch gleich wieder in Wallung kommen können.
Absolut. Das ist jetzt unser neues Intro.
So romantisch, so romantisch, so ein Lied, was alle hören sollten und alle haben sollten. Aber leider soll es irgendwie nicht sein, oder?
Es soll nicht so wirklich sein, äh das ist das Lied Dragonfly, der Band Texas Radio Fisch, über das wir hier vor einigen Folgen schon einmal gesprochen haben. Kannst du dir jetzt mal ausmachen, wenn das.
Mach dich ganz wuschig, stimmt's?
Äh genau ähm wir erinnern uns, äh es war,
auf dem Musikpiraten Sampler mit CC lizensierter Musik. Ähm und die Gamer verweigerte dem dem Musikpiraten EV die Bestätigung,
ähm dass dieser Song Gamer frei ist. Ähm dass wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, wenn man also, wenn man eine CD brennen möchte, weil also in so einem Presswerk, dann muss man dem,
Äh dem demjenigen, dem man den Auftrag gibt, jetzt diese CD zu vervielfältigen.
Ähm eine Bestätigung der GEMA geben, dass da kein GEMA-Kram drauf ist, weil sonst äh würde,
Wenn derjenige es ohne diese Bestätigung macht, dann würde er quasi Schuld auf sich laden, weil er diese Vervielfältigung äh gemacht hat, ohne dass das äh der Gamerkram geklärt war
ja? Das heißt immer, man geht dahin, sagt hallo, ich möchte hier die CD brennen und dann sagt er ja, wie sieht das aus mit GEMA, hast du irgendwie eine Bescheinigung, dass du den Wisch bezahlt hast oder dass das alles geh mal frei ist?
Und ähm.
Diese Bescheinigung hat die GEMA ähm verweigert für diesen Musikpiraten EV. Wie gesagt, so ein kleiner Verein, die da irgendwie mal ab und zu so Musikwettbewerbe im Internet äh machen und dann da ähm CC ähm,
Musik irgendwie küren, ja, also mit denen wollte die GEMA sich dann anlegen
und sagte, ja nee, hier das ist äh unter Pseudonym und da greift dann die Gamervermutung, wenn ihr uns wenn ihr nicht sagen könnt, wie die
wenn ihr uns nicht sagt, wie diese Person heißen und dann müssen wir davon ausgehen, dass sie bei uns unter Vertrag sind und deswegen wollen wir dafür gerne GEMA-Gebühren haben.
Und hat dann äh vor dem Landgericht Frankfurt auf die Lizenzgebühren geklagt,
Das ist ein sehr geringer Streitwert gewesen. Hm irgendwie ein zweistelliger Betrag. Ähm
Aber der Klage wurde dann äh äh also der der Fall wurde dann verhandelt, weil er eben so eine grundsätzliche Fragestellung.
Wertgeklagt die Piraten oder die GEMA? Ja.
Und die wollten gerne die Kohle haben,
Und diese diese zentrale Frage, was äh gilt die Gamervermutung bei Pseudonym? Die sollte also jetzt vor einem Gericht dann entschieden werden, weil also die die Sache ist klar, wir hatten also die GEMA äh.
Lizenzmodell gilt ja für einen Künstler und alles von diesem Künstler.
Und die CC-Lizenz gilt ja für ein bestimmtes Werk. Das ist ja genau diese Inkompatibilität, wenn ich einmal bei der GEMA bin, kann ich keine CC lizenzierte Musik mehr veröffentlichen,
weil ähm alles, was ich mache, automatisch durch die GEMA.
Ist mit der Person und nicht mit nicht über das Werk, sondern über das Schaffen.
Über das gesamte Schaffen dieser,
und jetzt wär's natürlich eine eine Möglichkeit zu sagen, okay, wenn ich Ziellizenzensierte Musik machen möchte, mein eigener Name, aber mit dem GEMA, mit der GEMA assoziiert ist, dann mache ich das unter Pseudonym. Und genau da sagt die Gemma, nee, äh machen wir nicht,
wollen wir nicht. Und die ähm die Frage oder es ist aber gar nicht klar, ob diese Texas Radio Fischleute.
Tatsächlich bei der GEMA sind oder nicht, weil sie sind ja unter Pseudonym.
Und deswegen äh greift eben an der Stelle dann die GEMA Vermutung. So und das wurde also jetzt vor Gericht verhandelt und ähm,
Das Landgericht Frankfurt sagte dann, ja ähm wir geben der Klage statt, also die Musikpiraten verlieren vor Gericht und müssen zahlen.
Das Landgericht Frankfurt hat aber die Berufung zugelassen.
Und das heißt, das wird dann äh wird dann irgendwie nochmal weiter äh besprochen, ja. Der entscheidende Faktor war also, dass die ähm.
Dass die dass die Gamer da jetzt offensichtlich erstmal ein Urteil in den Händen hat, was die GEMA Vermutung stärkt. Und zwar zu einem Ausmaß, was es eigentlich anders herum unmöglich macht, Musik,
unter einem Pseudonym zu veröffentlichen.
Dann immer die GEMA kassieren würde, ja? Egal was ist, wenn ich irgendwas unter Pseudonym mache, egal welche Lizenz ich dran schreibe, würde die GEMA hinkommen und sagen, nee, ist nicht.
Das U oder könnte sie hinkommen. Das Urhebergesetz sieht aber ähm die Möglichkeit zur Pseudonym und anonym Veröffentlichung vor,
Äh und startet die dann auch mit dieser siebzigjährigen Schutzfrist und so weiter aus. Und das beanspruchen die Musikpiraten jetzt natürlich auch für die äh Querative Lizenzen.
Ähm und die Musikpiraten argumentieren, na ja, wenn jemand ähm,
bei der GEMA ist, dann kann er der Gamer ja auch die Pseudonyme melden, also wenn man irgendwie diesen Bushido nimmt, der heißt ja auch, der ist ja auch nicht als Bushido auf die Welt gekommen, sondern der heißt irgendwie Yusef Aha Siri oder wat und äh hat dann der GEMA gesagt, aber wenn irgendwo Bushido dransteht, ne
hier icke. So und ähm das.
Ist also ein ein interessanter, ein interessanter Fall, weil es wäre also diese Gamervermutung ja, macht eben ähm,
Macht eben in der heutigen Zeit dann Probleme. Und wie gesagt, berührt eben dieser Fall, berührt diesen zentralen,
Der des Urheberrechtsgesetzes, ob Pseudonym und anonyme Veröffentlichung.
Aber ich meine, das ist jetzt noch nicht ausgeschwitzt. Ich meine, das ist ja äh eine Amtsgerichtsentscheidung. Da kann man doch auch äh kann man doch auch eine Berufung einlegen.
Das war auch der Fehler. Ich habe gerade die ganze Zeit Landgericht gesagt. Landgericht ist das, wo es als nächstes hingeht. Das war jetzt erst mal nur das Amtsgericht. Weil ich gerade die ganze Zeit vorm Landgericht war.
Oder heißt es Landesgericht?
Da ist sie wieder, die Konfusion. Okay, wir werden das verfolgen ähm,
Das wäre natürlich schon ein bisschen hart. Ich meine, diese Klimavermutung halte ich ja generell für äh fragwürdig
und das ist eh etwas, was äh auch gerne mal vom Verfassungsgericht äh äh landen dürfte. Ähm ja, aber das müssen wir natürlich äh sehen, wie sich das jetzt äh
entwickelt.
Ja, ich bin, also man darf da gespannt sein. Ist auf jeden Fall eine,
'ne interessante Frage und jetzt also wie gesagt beginnt jetzt erstmal mit einer Niederlage und einer Stärkung der Gamervermutung allerdings eben durch so ein Amtsgerichtsurteil. Und die Musikpiraten werden da auch in Berufung gehen. Aber ähm,
Sollte dieser Fall dann tatsächlich vor irgendeinem hohen Gericht landen, dann hast du da eben den Präzedenzfall, ne, also müssen die Musikpiraten jetzt zusehen. Ähm.
Also ich fänd's sehr spannend, wenn sie das Ass im Ärmel haben, dass die Leute, die sich hinter dem Pseudonym verbergen, auch tatsächlich nicht bei der GEMA sind. Weil das wäre auf jeden Fall dann.
Ja, ja gut, das ja, also das ist ja, das wissen sie ja auch nicht, oder? Also, ich meine, sind die bekannte irgendjemanden.
Sie argumentieren äh also die die Musikpiraten sagen, dass diese Person ihre bürgerliche äh Existenz nicht mit,
Diesem künstlerischen Schaffen, unter diesem Namen äh verbunden haben wollen, Punkt.
Und das ist das muss ausreichen, ja? Also da das scheint eben durch das Urheberrechtsgesetz auch durchaus so äh vorgesehen zu sein.
Aber ich meine, wenn man das jetzt mal anders rumdreht, aus der GEMA-Perspektive, wäre das ja quasi das Schlupfloch, unter dem jeder, der einen GEMA-Vertrag hat, dann trotzdem noch irgendwie ohne GEMA veröffentlichen könnte.
Und es stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, ob nicht sogar so etwas auch in gewisser Hinsicht zulässig.
Wäre.
Man ja explizit es nicht mit dem eigenen Schaffen in Verbindung bringt und damit sozusagen, aber das ist äh juristisch ganz interessant.
Vielleicht mal wieder was für den Moment, wo wir uns mal hier einen Juristen als Gast äh äh reinholen, um eine kostenlose Beratung abzuholen.
Genau, also aber du hast es genau erfasst. Es wäre im umgekehrten Fall natürlich das Schlupfloch für alle äh die in die in die GEMA gefesselt sind. Wir hatten ja auch äh einmal äh sich Doktor Motte zum Thema GEMA,
zitiert hatte, äh festgestellt, dass es auch sehr schwierig ist, da wieder herauszukommen. Und äh das wäre natürlich dann eben die Möglichkeit,
für für Musiker erstens sich relativ schnell von der GEMA zu lösen, so im Sinne von the Artist und jetzt mache ich.
Ja, beziehungsweise eben nicht das, sondern.
Genau. Ja, also ähm.
Man muss erstmal zwei Jahre versteckt undercover produzieren und danach darf man erst sagen, das war ich übrigens.
Dann sagst du hättet ihr es gedacht, ja.
Na ja, es ist ein interessanter Grenzfall, also von daher sehe ich diese Geschichte auch noch ein bisschen höher wandern.
Ja ja, auf jeden Fall. Es ist ein ist ein es ist wirklich ein ein wichtiger Fall, der da jetzt verhandelt wird. Und der sollte natürlich hoffentlich so enden vor einem hohen Gericht, dass die Gamer Vermutung schwächt. Ähm.
Wenn man sagen möchte, man möchte irgendwie sage ich mal, eine Lösung haben, die irgendwie zum Wohle aller ist.
Gut,
Zum Wohle aller äh ist ja auch unsere Bundes äh Regierung eingestellt und äh möchte sozusagen nur Dinge beschließen, die auch zum Wohle der breiten Masse.
Sind, es sei denn, es geht um die Verlage, da geht's natürlich nur um das Wohl der Verlage, deswegen gibt's jetzt äh die dritten Gesetzesentwurf zum Leistungsschutzrecht.
Meiner Meinung nach ein Kandidat,
für die von Gesetzen, die so dermaßen äh eine Bauchlandung erleben werden, noch bevor sie äh äh beschlossen sind.
Bevor sie sozusagen mal wirklich, also wo überhaupt erstmal versucht wird, sie zu beschließen. Ich habe so den Eindruck, es wird soweit nicht kommen, aber vielleicht werde ich da auch äh liege ich da auch falsch.
Aber es gibt jetzt sozusagen, nachdem der letzte Stand ja irgendwie im Wesentlichen somit äh Lex Google äh schon äh in die Vergangenheit eingesunken ist, weil da ja eigentlich nichts mehr drin stand, als er Suchmaschinen sind böse und haben gefälligst zu bezahlen.
Alle müssen nicht bezahlen, außer äh Anbieter von Suchmaschinen.
Genau und jetzt gab's wieder eine neue Variante und man hat sich hingesetzt und lange beschlossen und herauskam, was?
Zulässig ist die öffentliche Zugänglichmachung von Presseerzeugnissen oder Teilen hiervon, soweit sie nicht durch gewerbliche Anbieter von Suchmaschinen oder gewerbliche Anbieter von Diensten erfolgt, die Inhalt entsprechend aufbereiten.
Hm auf Deutsch heißt das, es ist nicht, es ist weiterhin Lex Google Plus,
was weiß ich, River, Perlentaucher und äh solche anderen Dienste. Die sind jetzt wieder mit drin.
Und ähm das Wort gewerblich, äh da hatte sie sich, glaube ich, Udo Vetta auch nochmal äh zu geäußert, ähm,
Da haben wir natürlich genau das gleiche äh Problem, dass es relativ unscharf definiert ist, ne, also ihr macht's jetzt der Flatterbutton oder der Amazon ähm,
Affiliate-Link, die Sache zu gewerblich oder nicht und äh ja, River zum Beispiel hat ja einen Sponsor irgendwie Renault oder so. Ähm und äh solche
ähm,
Solche Konstellationen würden das dann eben gewerblich machen und äh nach dem Text, den jetzt das Kabinett beschlossen hat, also das ähm.
Das Bundeskabinett hat jetzt das beschlossen, möchte das jetzt so in den Bundestag hineinreichen.
Welcher dann darüber entscheiden soll, äh das zum Gesetz zu machen. So weit sind wir jetzt. Also, das heißt, dieser äh dieser
Diese diese dritte Fassung jetzt vom Kabinett beschlossen soll in den in den Bundestag gehen. Äh Markus äh schrieb bei bei Netzpolitik und in einer
Pressemitteilung des Vereins digitale Gesellschaft, dass man auf das Gesetz hofft,
Das strukturische Gesetz besagt, dass kein Gesetz den Bundestag so verlässt, wie es hineingekommen ist.
Das wäre jetzt mal spannend, weil das das wäre so eine Art Wirkungsnachweis für für Bundestagsdebatten. Ähm.
Kann ich jetzt, also kann ich jetzt.
Wenn sie denn stattfinden.
Wenn sie, wenn sie denn stattfinden, also ich meine, wir haben ja, was hatten wir letztens doch für ein schönes Gesetz, was da in sechzig Sekunden durchgegangen ist. Also, ich meine, das hat ja relativ wenig Änderungen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Ja die Debattenkultur war da auch sehr ausgeprägt so, ne? Da wurden halt ein paar Din-A4-Seiten auf den Tisch gelegt und äh das war dann die Debatte.
Podcast so machen. Ja, also wurde äh der Inhalt dieses Podcasts wurde vorab niedergelegt,
schriftlich niedergelegt? Wie wie war denn die Formulierung für solche äh äh Reden, die nur per Text äh ausgedruckt äh abgegeben werden sind, irgendwie vorgelegt worden oder sind schriftlich liegen vor und werden aber nicht vorgelesen?
Wir würden das machen.
Ja. Haben wir gemacht. Habe haben wir alles besprochen. Kann man nachlesen.
Das nennt man dann Block.
So und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt war ein, übrigens, eine sehr äh das fand ich einen sehr tollen äh sehr tolle Sammlung bei Netzpolitik org. Und zwar alle.
Ähm öffentlichen Äußerungen zu diesem zu diesem Beschluss, ne? Also Google äh sagt natürlich, korrekt äh,
Netzpolitiker aller Parteien, gesamte deutsche Wirtschaft führende Wissenschaftler und die deutsche Internetgemeinde äh lehnen das Leistungsschutzrecht unisono ab,
äh stimmt. Ähm der Bitcom sagt ähm Bundesregierung will das Gesetz gegen die grundsätzliche Kritik von Unternehmen, Bloggern, Internetexperten durchsetzen. Ähm,
plant damit ein weltweit einmaligen Alleingang, äh der an internationale Gründer und Investoren ein ungutes Signal aussendet, innovative Online-Dienste sind in Deutschland nicht erwünscht
alles richtig, ne,
Piratenpartei betont, dass weder die Urheber noch die Netzwelt von der, von dem Leistungsschutzrecht profitiert und erwartet von den Verlegern, dass sie aus eigener Kraft ihre Geschäftsmodelle entwickeln,
Also alles, alles sehr, sehr richtige äh Äußerungen, die da getätigt wurden und ähm,
Die Grünen weisen darauf hin, ja, dass die Suchmaschinen den Verlegern, den Verlagen, natürlich die Besucher geben. Ähm.
Eigentlich haben wir schon alle verstanden, dass das Quatsch.
Es haben alle, genau, sie haben's auch wirklich verstanden. Das fand ich das Spannende. Es haben alle auch wirklich verstanden, ja? Und äh.
Ne, die Linke sagt, gibt's Rechtsunsicherheit? Eine SPD sagt der aktuelle, äh die bestehenden Verfahrensrechte reichen aus, aber dann wird's natürlich spannend. Was sagt die ähm was sagt denn die FDP und die CDU?
Äh und die FDP sagt, na ja, die Suchmaschinen brauchen ja nur eine Erlaubnis. Steht ja nicht, dass sie bezahlen müssen. Ähm,
die Erlaubnis dann an eine Gebühr gebunden ist, müssen die Beteiligten Parteien in der Praxis selber festlegen. Das Leistungsschutzrecht flankiert damit lediglich den Aufbau innovativer Geschäftsmodelle im Internet,
und bietet ein Abwehrinstrument gegen unberechtigte gewerbliche Nutzung. So sieht es die FDP.
Und die CDU sagt, bisher gibt es für Presseverlage keine gesetzliche Grundlage, um an den
gewinnen solcher Internetdienste beteiligt zu werden, obwohl diese auch auf ihrer schöpferischen Leistung beruhen. Künftig müssen die entsprechenden gewerblichen Anbieter eine Lizenz erwerben, um Presseerzeugnisse im Internet nutzen zu können.
Andere Nutzer wie Blogger, private und ehrenamtliche Nutzer
von dem Gesetzentwurf hingegen nicht erfasst. Ich bin mal gespannt, also ob ich eigentlich ehrenamtlicher Nutzer des Internets bin,
Das ist echt so was, was ich mir auf die Visitenkarte schreibe, ja?
Leser von Spiegel Online oder sowas.
Ehrenamtlicher Internetmitarbeiter.
Ehrenamtlicher, ja, also äh.
Das wäre doch mal was.
Und selbst die Junge Union. Junge Union fällt dann der der großen, der der alten Union in den Rücken und sagt ähm,
geplante Leistungsschutzrecht ist ein Eingriff auf die freiheitliche und marktwirtschaftliche Architektur des Internets und somit nicht im Sinne der Nutzer. Selbst die Junge Union hat's verstanden. Das ist etwas, was sehr selten passiert.
Ja, also ähm spannend, ja, man, also man man kann echt staunen. Es gab dann, was jetzt die Presse dann schreibt in der in der ähm.
Was in der war dann irgendwie so ein so ein Artikel, irgendwie so ein guter Tag für die Demokratie oder so was, ne? Ein guter Tag für die Freiheit oder irgendwie so ein aber ernst gemeint, ne, also,
Ja, ja, ist ja irgendwie, also ich, das das Flug war am Twitter an mir vorbei, konnte ich gar nicht zu Ende lesen.
Nicht dieser Schirmacher irgendwie.
Ja, ich habe äh ja äh.
Ganz gut vernetzt und und und redet auch irgendwie. Also ich meine hallo?
Ich glaube äh ich habe gar keine genaue Ahnung, äh wie.
Die haben alle das Memo nicht gelesen. Das ist äh.
Ich glaube eher, sie haben's gelesen, wenn du mich fragst.
Ich suche mal grade ganz kurz, ob ich euch diesen guter Tag für die Freiheit. Äh Reinhard Müller in der Fatz müssen wir dann auch noch hier verlinken, ne. Ähm.
Die sehen das also sehen das als besonders gut. Tja.
Freiheit, ne? Ich denke äh äh die Freiheit würde in dem Fall doch eher dadurch vorankommen, dass man in Deutschland mal
Ja genau, über das Gegenteil nachdenkt, nämlich dass man mal diesen Faire definiert
und nicht so äh äh alles schwammig lässt. Also es wäre eigentlich viel sinnvoller, da mal zu sagen
Okay äh äh geschützt okay meinetwegen, ja, aber es muss auch einfach Bereiche geben, wo man klar eine freie Nutzung nötig ist, weil überall da, wo es eben nicht offensichtlich
entweder ein vorsätzlicher Gewinnerwerb ist oder wo
ist zumindest klar ist, dass hier auf so 'ner sekundären Ebene auch ein Nutzen für den ursprünglichen Urheber einfach stattfindet, ja?
Nutzung in der Wikipedia äh et cetera. Oder eben sowas wie die Google News Geschichte. Ja.
Google News hat noch nicht mal Werbung drauf.
Kühlt Millionen von Nutzern pro Sekunde irgendwo hin, die dann dort äh den Kram lesen. Ähm und River äh dieses sehr tolle Projekt von Frank Westphal, was ja äh so ein bisschen,
also Twitter mitguckt und so, so schaut, was ist gerade heiß.
Google News mit mit Social Media.
Social Media, also das Ding wurde vor einem Jahr oder was äh eingestampft, weil der keine äh Energie mehr hatte, das zu unterhalten. Und wie gesagt, dieser äh Fahrzeughersteller Citroen äh der das dann jetzt äh sponsert.
Ich meine das war VW.
Ja, also ein ein Fahrzeughersteller hat es jetzt ähm äh sponsert dieses dieses Projekt jetzt so. Ich ich habe keine Ahnung, was der da für.
Kommt, ja. Ja.
Kommt, ja? Aber ähm,
dass er es vorher eingestellt hat und jetzt mit dieser kleinen äh Werbeanzeige da oben drin äh sponsert bei äh äh Opel äh weiterführt, ja. Ähm das zeigt ja schon, dass der da äh
jetzt gerade irgendwie das Haus abbezahlt hat damit, ne und so also totaler totaler Unsinn. Ähm.
Würde überhaupt an gar keine Nachrichten mehr kommen. Das ist Hardcore.
So und ähm also ein ein unglaublich spannendes,
unglaublich unsinniges Gesetz. Ich kann dazu noch empfehlen, die Folge vom elektrischen Reporter zu diesem Thema,
Da kam dann ähm ich glaube, der äh von Google, ich glaube nicht, dass das der Kai Overbeck war, aber irgend so ein anderer Sprecher von Google, ne
dann der Till Kreuzer von und der Christoph Käse äh zu Wort. Christoph Käse hier, der der Axel-Springer-Lobby ist. Der ähm wie.
Verbrochen hat sozusagen.
Der es verbrochen hat. Ja und es war, es war immer so, man ähm man war immer eigentlich dazu geneigt zu sagen, das ist alles auf dessen Mist gewachsen.
Und er gibt es auch zu, es ist alles auf seinem Miss gewachsen, das ist sein Kind. Es ist wirklich also einfach mal ein auch ein ein beispielloser Fall davon, dass ein ein Lobbyist, das
auch so offen sagt, ja, die kämpfen da ja seit ein paar Jahren für so und das ist seine Arbeit. Er, das heißt, er,
Sag bei dieser elektrischen Reporterfolge auch, dass er sich das quasi ausgedacht hat und erstmal seinen Arbeitgeber davon überzeugen musste, also die Achsel-Springer-Verlag, ähm dass er jetzt Lobby für diese Sache macht,
der hat das jetzt echt einfach durchgepeitscht, ja? Bis zu einem ähm bis zu einem Kabinettsentwurf, ja? Und das geht jetzt in den Bundestag
Und ähm ich meine, was von man muss nur meinen Text lesen in dieser man schreibt, um ungefähr ähm beurteilen zu können, äh wie differenz, wie differenziert so sein sein Wahrnehmungs- und Denkvermögen ist. Und ähm,
wenn man dann noch ein bisschen weiter reinschaut, dann merkt man, dass er in der Tat vielleicht gar nicht so völlig aus Holz ist, wie man meint, ähm weil er sich, glaube ich, seiner Situation schon relativ ähm.
Relativ klar ist und da halt äh das tut, was er denkt, was im Sinne seines Arbeitgebers ist. Also so äh wer mal eine ähm,
Studie äh eine eine Hausarbeit in in in sozial sozialwissenschaften schreiben muss zum Thema
Parlament, Lobbyismus, Entscheidungsfindung und so. Da ist echt mal ein spannendes Thema gerade was zu untersuchen.
Sich eignet, ja. Naja, Leistungsschutzrecht. Wir hoffen mal, dass irgendwo noch ein bisschen Besinnung in in die Angelegenheit kommt.
Sieht nicht so aus, aber ich ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht also wo wo nimmt die Bundesregierung diese Energie her da äh,
Am laufenden Meter sich äh von Fettnäpfchen zu äh Fettnäpfchen zu bewegen. Ich meine, das ist doch im Prinzip ist dieses Leistungsschutzrecht, das ist doch so wie wie die Nummer mit den Hotel äh Umsatzsteuersenkungen gleich ganz zum Anfang.
Genau das gleiche Teil dermaßen um die Ohren fliegen. Wobei ich halt auch glaube, dass es wirklich den Verlängern um die Ohren klingt, weil bisher, Google sagt es halt nicht, das war ja auch sehr schön in diesem,
elektrischen Reporterding also übrigens dort wurde Ralph Bremer von Google Deutschland befragt Position ist mir jetzt gerade ein bisschen unklar das,
So nach dem Motto ja wolltet ihr sie dann aussperren oder nicht?
So und dann so war im Wesentlichen, na ja, kein Kommentar. Wir sagen auf jeden Fall nicht, es will's nicht tun und da sie es ja schon mal getan haben, nämlich in Belgien, denke ich mal, ist das für sie einen Klacks.
Ja, ich glaube auch, da ist.
Ich meine, die könnten im Prinzip jetzt die ganzen, dieses gesamten gesamten Gesetzesprozess könnten sie im Prinzip jetzt auch schon abschließen, indem sie sagen, ach na ja, okay, wenn das jetzt kommt, dann schalten wir schon mal ab,
So, bevor das überhaupt in den Bundestag äh ordentlich debattiert wurde, durch das Hinlegen von Zetteln und äh ich glaube, bis dahin würde dann Herr Käse da selber wieder anrufen und schwitzend sagen, äh.
Ihr müsst äh.
Noch keiner ahnen, dass sie das wirklich macht.
Ja, ich glaube sowas die was Google machen muss, ist irgendwie, was ist das.
Ich sehe schon die Bildkamp, die Bildkampagne gegen Google, das wird auch schwierig werden.
A zwei Disside News. EC, ETC, NED, Apache, zwei Reload.
Es auch noch. Vielleicht kommt das auch noch, vielleicht haben wir noch irgendwie ja hier Kinderpornografie über Google gefunden und Google äh tut ja nichts dagegen und so. Das das würde einfach gut ins Bild passen.
Ein weiterer Aspekt, den wir vielleicht noch kurz benennen müssen, ist ähm,
Was auch in dem elektrischen Reporter so schön ausgearbeitet ist, äh dass natürlich die Definition des ähm Presse,
Verlages natürlich wieder so schwammig ist, dass es sehr einfach ist
sein eigener zu sein und das natürlich es dazu führen wird, äh sage ich mal, zu verhältnismäßig windigen Geschäftsmodellen, dass man einfach anfängt, Leute abzumahnen, ja, also schlechten Content generiert, den irgendwo in irgendwelche RSS-Feeds reinschleust
und hofft, dass ähm,
dass der irgendwo anders wieder auftaucht und man dann irgendwelche Leute, die die RSS-Feats bei sich einbinden oder so, dann dann abmahnen kann oder so, ne.
Also wieder mal, ja.
Beschäftigungstherapie für unterbeschäftigte Abmahnanwälte.
Hoffen wir, dass es irgendwie äh nicht so weit kommt.
Das nächste Thema ist weiterhin noch, wir bleiben beim Urheberrecht und zwar hat die ähm.
Lobby für Warnhinweis. Nee, die die die Lobby bestehend aus ähm.
Dem Bundesverband der Musikindustrie, der GVU, der Gesellschaft zur Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsverletzungen und der Börsenverein des Deutschen Buchhandels, die ja in der Content Allianz,
ihren losen Verbund haben, die haben eine Studie vorgestellt.
Ähm Studie zur digitalen Content Nutzung zweitausendzwölf und ähm haben da eine ganze Menge Fragen drin gestellt und hauptsächlich zielen sie darauf ab, ähm.
Äh
eine, also das, warum sie die Studie durchgeführt haben, ist, damit sie sie veröffentlichen können mit dem mit der Pressemitteilung, hoher Akzeptanz von Sanktionen und Warnhinweismodellen bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen in der Bevölkerung,
So, die haben da so Fragen gestellt, also ich zitiere mal so ein bisschen was aus den Ergebnissen, die sie da erlangt haben, irgendwie siebenundsiebzig Prozent sehen ein,
siebenundsiebzig Prozent der Befragten sehen ein Bußgeld für äh Urheberrechtsverletz äh für Anbieter von urheberrechtlich geschützten Material
als angemessen an dreiundfünfzig Prozent sehen Bußgelder als angemessen an für Leute, die herunterladen.
Ähm siebenundvierzig Prozent sehen eine zeitweise Aussetzung des Internetanschlusses als angemessene Sanktionen und nur siebenundzwanzig
für Anbieter, ja? Und nur siebenundzwanzig Prozent sehen eine zeitweise Aussetzung des Internetanschlusses für herunterladende,
Als angemessen an. Also immer die Unterscheidung Anbieter und Herunterladener, wobei das ja bei, sage ich mal, gängigen Methoden genau nicht zu trennen ist, ob du herunterladender bist oder anbietender bist. Also
über Torens, dann isst man beides gleichzeitig. Darüber laufen ja auch heutzutage die ganzen Abmahnungen,
dass man eben immer in gewerblichem Ausmaß anbietender ist, wenn man sich in einem tollen Schwarm äh aufhält. Und ähm das die entscheidende Frage,
Ähm also hier geht's so ausschalten und Warnhinweise. Die entscheidende Fragestellung war.
Und da man fragt sich ja, wie kommt's auf einmal, dass dass siebenundsiebzig Prozent der Befragten sagen, ja Bußgeld und so finden wir alles in Ordnung. Ist natürlich immer eine eine Überlegung oder eine Frage dessen, wie man die Frage stellt.
Und die Frage lautete, halten sie es für sinnvoll, wenn Menschen, die unberechtigt Inhalte aus dem Internet herunterladen, einen Warnhinweis ihres Providers bekommen, bevor rechtliche Sanktionen eingeleitet werden.
Würde ich doch auch sagen, ist doch super, ne? Ist doch klar, ich kriege eine Warnung und keine rechtliche Sanktion,
Ähm klingt doch echt sinnvoll. Zweiundsiebzig Prozent sagen natürlich dann auch jo.
Klar, bevor ich irgendwie einen auf den Sack kriege, möchte ich erstmal gewarnt werden. Ist ja.
Ja, nach dem Motto und und die nächste Frage ist dann äh, lass mich raten, äh finden sie's sinnvoll, dass hier eine Geldstrafe ausgesprochen wird, bevor wir da äh äh körperliche Folter anwenden.
Genau ja genau ähm halten sie's, halten sie's, ja.
Oh Gott.
So, also man kann eine Frage kaum.
Das stand aber jetzt nicht so drin.
Nein, aber es ist es ist natürlich ganz klar, wie du es schaffst, äh eine so hohe Akzeptanz für diese Frage zu bekommen, weil sie einen sehr klaren ähm eine sehr,
klaren Fall anspricht und eine böse Alternative hinstellt.
Ja. Psychologisch sehr geschickt.
Ja, wenn du die Frage stellst, halten sie es für sinnvoll, dass ihr Internetprovider verpflichtet wird, ihren Internetanschluss zu überwachen.
Und ähm na ihnen,
Verbotsschilder aufzustellen, wenn sie gegen das Urheberrecht verstoßen. Und ultimativ sie damit zu sanktionieren, dass ihnen der Internetanschluss abgedreht wird. So wie es in äh Frankreich und ich glaube auch in in England formal im Moment Gesetz ist.
Aber nicht in nicht in der Form stattfindet, weil diese weil diese äh Gesetze auch äh einem großen Protest und und äh großen Schwierigkeiten gegenüberstehen. Ähm dann würdest du natürlich andere Antworten bekommen,
Ja, also ähm.
So, also sie haben da jetzt eine Studie durchgeführt und haben diese diese mit durch mit suggestiven Fragen eindeutig suggestiven Fragen eben diese Antworten bekommen.
Und sagen, ja prima, das ähm äh veröffentlichen wir.
Und machen damit Druck auf die Justizministerin und sagen hier äh die Bevölkerung will das Warnhinweismodell.
Ja, sieht jetzt so aus. Also die Studie ist da, da können sie.
Ja, ja, klar. Die Zahlen lügen nicht.
Es muss jetzt jemand erstmal nochmal mit, sage ich mal, vernünftigen Ansatz so eine Frage stellen. Äh und dieses Geld aufbringen
sah ich meine Gegenerhebung zu machen, um nachzuweisen, was der Effekt, dass das ein Effekt der Fragestellung an dieser Stelle ist, ja? Und das ist ja nicht nur bei dieser einen Frage so.
Das ist ja bei den anderen Fragen auch so.
So und jetzt jetzt sagt dann die äh die Justizministerin als Reaktion auf äh auf die Veröffentlichung dieser Studie, in der sie ganz klar,
aufgefordert wird so, ne,
Schnarrenberger äh wendet sich hier gegen den Bevölkerungswillen so ungefähr, ne? Äh sagt's in die also Warnhinweismodelle ist ein Angst, äh ist ein Angstmodell,
wird es nicht geben, ja. Und äh um nochmal zu rekapitulieren, die Gründe dafür liegen eben auf der Hand, es muss der
Provider wird quasi verpflichtet dein dein Internetanschluss zu überwachen, wird irgendwie zu so einer Hilfspolizei ohne ohne äh rechtliche Basis, ja. Und diese ähm Warnhinweise, denen muss natürlich.
Oder so ist der Plan, den soll natürlich eine Sanktion folgen. Sonst ist das ja Quatsch. Ähm.
Und also das ist wirklich eine eine unglaublich,
Äh also das ist wirklich ein Eingriff ins Internet, der ein Ausmaß darstellt, dass eigentlich in keinem anderen der Kämpfe, die wir irgendwie äh ums Internet führen.
So in dem Ausmaß erreicht wird,
Das ist echt ein also Warnhinweismodelle und Vollüberwachung. Da ist Internetanschluss ist so vielen Dank. Also das das das einzige was dann,
Also dann müssen alle noch mal zu ihrem Internetanschluss irgendwie nochmal das Doppelte zahlen, um ernst zu nehmendes VPN zu haben, um in dem wo in in freie Länder äh zu kommen.
Ja. Ja, aber irgendwie an der Stelle zumindest nicht unbedingt grade besonders aufgeschlossen zu sein. Das äh ist ja nach wie vor hoch anzurechnen. Ähm.
Ja, da da kann man, also ja, sie,
Da ist sie wirklich äh eisern. Es wird sich natürlich jetzt zeigen, wie stark jetzt da aus den,
Aus den Löchern gefeuert wird, ne, weil auf sowas wie eine, also die Idee von diesem, von der Content Allianz da einfach mal so eine Erhebung zu machen, ne. Ist natürlich gut.
Tja, muss man mal eine Gegenstudie mit richtigen Fragen machen. Ich glaube, das sieht dann schon gleich ganz anders aus, ne.
Genau, kostet aber auch ein Schweinegeld.
Ja, das ist wahr.
Ne, also das ist echt, also ich meine.
Da muss ich echt sagen, Hut ab äh an den an die Lobby lobbyistische Strategie, die sie da fahren, so eine vergleichsweise so eine Erhebung für für so einen Lobbyverband, ist das natürlich sind das Peanuts und Erebung zu machen.
Hat jetzt äh weiß ich nicht, in fünfstelligen Betrag gekostet mit den ganzen Fragen und Auswertungen oder so. Und dann sagen sie äh hier, ne, repräsentative Erhebung steht noch irgendwie Infratest oder was dran oder welcher Verein die welche
Abfrageunternehmen da, die zehntausend Leute befragt hat oder so, ne? Und ähm.
Fertig ist, ja? Wunderbar. Also haben sie jetzt ein tolles Druckmittel und irgendjemand muss jetzt hingehen und da die Gegenerhebung machen, um einfach mal dieses ähm erstens das das Bild gerade zu rücken und auch mal
zum hundertmillionsten Mal zu zeigen, was von solchen Erhebungen überhaupt zu halten ist, ja? Weil der der Effekt der Fragestellung ist einfach enorm.
Ja
Na ja, ich meine, ist die Frage, ob das jetzt wirklich erforderlich ist. Es wäre natürlich schön, wenn es passiert, also es wäre, sagen wir mal durchaus mal äh etwas für eine äh digitale Organisation, die da sich äh entsprechend einsetzt, ne? Ich meine, wie vielleicht wäre das ja hier mal was für die vierundsechzig.
Ja, also ich denke, die, ich weiß, dass von einigen Personen, dass die die Debatte äh geführt wird, wie man das
macht und wie man vor allem wie man das bezahlt bekommt, ne? Also das ist ein, wie gesagt, das ist relativ viel Geld, was man da ähm in die Hand nehmen muss, um das um das ernsthaft durchzuführen.
Ja, ich glaube, Crowdfunding wird ein ständiger Begleiter sein für den Aktivismus der nächsten Zeit. Da kommen wir nicht drum rum. Ist ja auch richtig so. Jo, aber mit Abmahnungen sind wir noch nicht durch, oder?
Nee, mit Abmahnung sind wir noch nicht durch. Ähm es gibt ja noch die, die schöne Kanzlei,
U und C, Urmann und Kollegen, Kollegen mit C geschrieben, keine Ahnung, irgendwie, na gut, Jura hat ja auch nicht so einen hohen NC. Also, Urmann und Kollegen ähm irgendwie haben angekündigt, sie wollen ab dem ersten neunten ähm,
Gegnerlisten online stellen. Und ähm äh.
Also wofür ist diese Kanzlei jetzt bekannt?
Massenabmahnungen. Die äh die sind darauf spezialisiert, also sagen sie auch selber zu unserem Mandanten zählen unter anderem auch Auftraggeber,
der Erotikbranche, die ihre Urheberrechte verletzt sehen, Gegenstand der Urberrechtsverletzung ist das unerlaubte Herunterladen eines urheberrechtlich geschützten Werkes in Verbindung mit dem gleichzeitigen Anbieten des Werkes durch Freigabe auf der Festplatte für,
zum Download für weitere Internetnutzer, also ne? Und was die jetzt machen wollen, ist ähm.
Also die dieser ganze Abmahnungskram, es läuft ja in der Regel so, dass sie sagen, hier äh wir schicken dir eine Unterlassungserklärung und eine Rechnung,
und du überweist und ähm unterschreibst und wir sehen davon ab, die ganze Angelegenheit irgendwie vor Gericht zu bringen.
So läuft ja dieses Abmahn-Business und dann ähm sind sage ich mal im Großteil der Fälle
die Eltern sowieso schon böse genug auf das auf den Sohn oder die Tochter, die da irgendwas runtergeladen hat, zahlt denen
Zahlen den Quatsch, unterschreiben den Wisch und das Thema ist erledigt. Die etwas ähm sage ich mal, schlaueren Leute schicken eine modifizierte Unterlassungserklärung
und bezahlen erstmal nicht oder suchen sich anwaltlichen Beistand und versuchen die Sache irgendwie auszukämpfen, denn in der Regel sind diese Abmahn
die die finanziellen Förderungen, die da gestellt werden, ja auch enorm überzogen, ne. Ich hatte das ja letztens immer zitiert, die letzte Abmahnung, die ich gesehen habe, war achthundert Euro für einen Kinofilm in schlechter Qualität.
Das ist gängig, ja, ne.
Auch schon irgendwie zwölfhundert gesehen oder so, ne? Also das äh das sind also enorme.
Äh Gebühren, die da erhoben werden und nur nochmal zum Hintergrund, das läuft ja immer so ab, dass dieser Abmahn,
Preis ergibt sich aus einem theoretischen Streitwert,
Und aus diesem theoretischen Streitwert äh ergibt sich natürlich auch das, was die Kanzlei tatsächlich dafür bekommt, von,
Also es gibt quasi einen Teil des Geldes geht an den an den,
Inhaber, dessen Rechte da verteidigt werden. Ein anderer Teil des Geldes geht an an die Kanzlei. Die haben aber natürlich irgendwie schon längst das ganze ähm,
Das Ganze im Prinzip vollautomatisiert arbeiten mit technischen Anbietern zusammen, die einfach nur sich in alle äh Torens mit rein
klinken und einfach die gesamten IP-Adressen an die Kanzlei schicken. Da kommt aus der Datenbank direkt der Kettenbrief
Und äh dann wird nur noch geguckt, was auf dem Konto ankommt. Ja, also es ist eine relativ äh ist eine Gelddruckmaschine. Ja. Ja. Ähm so und.
Auch so auf Massengeschäft ausgelegt, dass sie so mit individuellen Rückfragen, das wäre dann schon wieder viel zu teuer.
Genau, also das das ist die ich denke mal, irgendwie fünf bis zehn Prozent Schwund haben die einfach mit drin.
Also indem man ihn sozusagen Arbeit macht, äh schafft man schon sich mal Ärger vom Hals.
Genau, also man man hat eigentlich relativ gute Aussichten, so was ich jetzt höre, wenn man ihnen Arbeit macht. Ähm,
weil es eben noch genug Leute gibt, die die da einfach, ja, schockiert sind und zahlen, ne? Ich denke, der hauptsächliche Fall sind eben dann Eltern, die,
so etwas bekommen und wenn da irgendwie
Briefe sind ja auch sehr äh bedrohlich. Es gibt einen, das müssen wir gleich auch noch verlinken. Es gibt einen schönen Artikel, äh wie man eine Massenabmahnung erkennt. Und ähm.
Der ist von einer, von einer Anwaltskanzlei, die häufig gegen so etwas verteidigt. Da ist das sehr schön, sage ich mal, auch diese Taktik äh dargestellt, ne, wo dann so drinsteht. Also der Brief ist ja im Prinzip so, du hast hier, du bist mit einem Bein im Knast,
Aber wir sind ja gütig und deswegen muss uns nur achthundert geben und dann lassen wir dich irgendwie ähm.
Mhm.
Drücken wir nochmal ein Auge zu. Und jetzt will diese äh Uhrmann und Kollegen, die wollen für diejenigen, die dann sagen, nee, äh hier.
Arsch lecken. Wir machen äh wir wir klären die Nummer jetzt mal,
für die den wollen sie quasi dann damit drohen, dass sie ihren Namen auf einer Internetseite wiederfinden,
Und dann noch mit diesen Erotikbranche äh Dingen irgendwie im Hintergrund. Ne, das heißt so,
da drin steht so hier nicht nur wollen wir achthundert Euro, weil du dir hier ein äh ein Film, so ein so ein Sahnewestern runtergeladen hast, ne. Wir wollen äh, dass wir wir schreiben das auch noch dem wir teilen das im Internet mit,
den Film runtergeladen hast, ne. Ähm und sie berufen sich damit auf ein Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil
das irgendwann mal festgelegt hat, dass ein Anwalt auch über seine Fälle berichten können muss, allerdings äh war das bei gewerblichen äh in gewerblichen Angelegenheiten und nicht bei Privatpersonen, ja.
Udo Fetter und Thomas Stadler haben natürlich dazu,
ihre fachliche Meinung abgegeben und sagen, dass das im Zweifelsfall, also ein derartiger Angriff auf das Persönlichkeitsrecht ist, ähm wenn nicht sogar äh die die Intimsphäre der Person.
Und das ist dadurch natürlich eine verfassungsrechtliche Abwägung gibt äh bei Privatpersonen, die anders ist, als als bei Unternehmen, ja? Ähm
Und das ist natürlich relativ offensichtlich so eine Prangerdrohung, Prangerwirkung, die da angestrebt wird, die ähm.
Auf gar keinen Fall äh Bestand haben sollte, also Udo Vetter sagte, wer jeder
würde Mandanten, die sich irgendwie ab ersten September auf so 'ner Liste finden sofort hier zu so 'ner einstweiligen Verfügung raten. Und die, die Angelegenheit muss natürlich
gefochten werden. Aber man sieht ähm.
Auch hier werden wir jetzt echt drei Themenbereich dreimal Themenbereich Urba Recht gehabt äh wie das abgeht. So die schießen jetzt wirklich aus ähm.
Aus allen Rohren, ne. Und die Kanzlei U und C sagte dann noch irgendwie, ähm ähm.
Dass dass sie das ganz gerne äh öffentlich machen,
Und die Zahl wollen sie aber nicht nennen, also ist irgendwie auch komisch, warum wollen sie ihr, warum wollen sie die Zahl nicht nennen, aber die Person, also sie wollen jetzt eine Drohkulisse für diejenigen haben, äh,
Ärger machen und nicht einfach zahlen. Also der Kampf wird echt inzwischen.
Ja, es ist vor allem, also ich muss auch sagen, es ist natürlich auch eine Beschädigung,
des der Branche, der Rechtsanwalter und ich freue mich in zunehmenden Maße, was eigentlich da die Verbände äh zu sagen, die das bestimmt äh lange stillschweigend mitgetragen haben und es wäre mal interessant, äh zu sehen,
was da äh Beschwerden von aufgeklärten äh Rechtsanwälten vielleicht mal bewirken könnte. Wie heißt denn hier so die größte Rechtsanwalts.
Verband ähm ja fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein, aber das das ist natürlich.
Deutsche Anwaltsverein.
Ist schon ja, ich glaube. Also sowas könnte man halt ähm da auch mal äh oder sollte man da auch mal thematisieren, ne? Weil das ist äh.
Von Namen. Ich meine, zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo ja noch gar nichts belegt ist,
Ja, wo ja nichts äh gerichtsfest ist et cetera und das sind ja quasi Unterstellungen. Und äh ich könnte mir auch durchaus vorstellen, dass das hier äh U plus C äh auch schwer wiederum Verleumdungs
Klagen einbringen könnte, weil,
der jetzt der Anschlussinhaber ist, derjenige, den sie da ermittelt haben, das können sie ja überhaupt gar nicht belegen, dass das derjenige ist, der das runtergeladen hat und der es äh also der Mark,
Theoretisch, ja, jemand sein, der haftbar gemacht werden kann, aber haftbar
sein und wirklich äh jemand sein, den man unterstellt, da auch Konsument äh äh zu sein oder auch Verbreiter, das steht ja nochmal auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Also ich glaube, die trauen sich hier einfach eine Menge und äh,
schwäbisch.
Das ist ganz schön schäbig, aber dieses also man muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, dieses dieses Business der Massenabmahnung.
Ist auch schon schäbig.
Also das ist wirklich enorm schäbig. Es ist einfach, das ist einfach bah. Also ähm,
Ne, also wirklich so eine so eine Automatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung und es ist ja ganz klar, dass diese ähm ach genau, sehr schön, es gab ja mal diesen Fall von einer,
Ah, da müsste ich jetzt lange suchen. Das wurde auf auf Spreeblick und und Netzpolitik org lange verhandelt. Eine Autorin, eine eine Redakteurin, freie, freie ähm Journalistin, die äh eine.
Auch auf das Angebot eingegangen war einer solchen äh Bude, ja? Und die dann irgendwie auch mal also da ging es irgendwie darum, dass Abmahnungen an irgendwelche Blogger gingen, die Stücke aus ihren Presseartikeln irgendwo zitiert hatten.
Und es stellte sich dann irgendwie heraus, diese Frau stellte dann klar, dass sie quasi angeschrieben wurde von einer Anwaltskanzlei, deren Angebot an sie mehr oder weniger lautete, du pass mal auf, ähm.
Wir kümmern uns darum, Leute zu suchen, die deine äh die dein Urheberrecht verletzen oder aus deinen Artikeln über die Gebühr zitieren. Wir schicken denen eine Abmahnung,
Und ähm nur wenn wir jemanden finden, zahlst du dann irgendwie.
Also kriegst du was weiß ich, fünfzig Prozent von der Kohle, die wir bekommen, abzüglich unserer Gebühren.
Und ähm eine Aufwandspauschale dafür, dass wir das ähm dass wir das gefunden haben. So ungefähr war der Deal. Das heißt, für die Frau stand äh entweder zur Wahl, zu sagen, jo mach ich und kriege eventuell Geld.
Muss aber überhaupt nichts bezahlen.
Ja oder ich mach's nicht und kriege kein Geld und muss nix bezahlen. Das heißt, das Angebot, was diese Abmahnkanzleien an die Rechteinhaber stellen, ist äußerst lukrativ.
Wir kümmern uns um alles, du musst nur uns den Auftrag dazu geben und am Ende des Monats bekommst du Geld überwiesen. Ja und natürlich ist dann bei den bei den Gebühren ähm,
Feststellungen sind dann natürlich nicht mehr, also wird natürlich dann das so umgangen, dass die dass die Abmahnkanzlei den größeren Teil davon bekommt des Geldes.
Normalerweise nicht vorgesehen ist, aber dadurch, dass sie das raussucht und dieses äh diese U plus C, die geben das ja sogar zu. Also es ist wirklich ein
Businessmodell abmahnt zu sein. Und zwar ein sehr gutes, ist ein Gelddruckmaschine.
Verwerflich. Wir äh prangern das an. Wir prangern das an. Genau und genau.
Wir prangern das an, an unserem kleinen Internetpranger hier.
So, aus der Abteilung, kleine Nachrichten, äh Beleben des Podcast äh Vermögen, was äh hast du entdeckt?
Ja ähm nur so kurzer kurzer Hinweis, also the Citizen Lab, die auch schon den den analysiert hatten,
also den Staatstrojaner aus dem Hause Gamma haben jetzt äh auch Samples von Myware für äh iOS, Symbien, Windows, Mobile, Android und Blackberry gefunden.
Ähm die sich ebenfalls zu äh bestimmten Servern verbindet, die mit hallo Steffi antworten.
Weiterhin in den.
Im Programmcode auch wieder äh bezüget mit zu dem Wort Finns beihaben und im Falle der iOS-Version sogar mit der Entwicklerlizenz von Martin Münch, unserem,
unserem Freund bei Gamma äh unterschrieben,
Also mit dem, mit diesem Zertifikat signiert sind. Das heißt, da gibt es also äh Mobiltelefon, von Gamma, äh die also.
Alle Plattformen einschließlich iOS.
Einschließlich iOS. Ähm die Analyse ist aber hauptsächlich jetzt erstmal nur auf die,
Selber bezogen und sie haben sich nicht so richtig dazu äußern können, wie der Infektionsweg ist, ob das irgendwie Hands On ist und äh oder ob man, ob das irgendwie über einen remotexploiter drauf geballert wurde,
Dazu haben sie jetzt erstmal wenig sagen können. Es schien sich dabei weiterhin um eine Demoversion zu handeln.
Also ist so ein bisschen unklar äh wieder der wieder der Infektionsweg ist, aber die äh Interessante ist auf jeden Fall,
Der Staatstrojaner auf dem Mobiltelefon. Und dazu äh ist auf jeden Fall zu sagen, wenn du heute,
Überwachungstrojaner bauen willst, dann ist natürlich das Mobiltelefon das Smartphone viel attraktiveres Ziel als der genutzte Rechner.
Bewährungsprofile, alles drauf gesünkt. Na ja.
Also äh Kommunikations äh Profile und so weiter sehr sehr viel besser äh äh zu entdecken als ähm,
als auf einem Rechner, gleichzeitig bist du natürlich in einem sehr, sehr viel privateren Bereich der Person.
Und ähm was die deutsche Gesetzeslage dazu sagt, kann ich kann ich gar nicht so äh kann ich gar nicht so genau sagen. Also wahrscheinlich viele das dann auch eben unter Quellen TKÜ,
unter der Vermutung, dass irgendwas verschlüsselt wird, andererseits werden ja hauptsächlich eigentlich der meiste Smartphone wischt, der ist ja eigentlich sowieso unverschlüsselt, ist jetzt irgendwie im Nachhinein erst vor ein paar Monaten wurden WhatsApp-Nachrichten,
an endlich mal irgendwie über SSL übertragen oder so, weil.
Vor ein paar Monaten das Update kam vor ein paar Tagen gehabt.
Vor ein paar Tagen, genau vor ein paar Monaten war diese äh war dann die Android-App draußen, die ähm im im offenen im lokalen WLAN irgendwie WhatsApp-Nachrichten schnorcheln konnte. Ähm.
Ähm.
Ja, also.
Das Ding ist da und als, als, als, als Ziel für für Überwachungsmywais, das ist das Mobiltelefon natürlich sehr, sehr viel, sehr, sehr viel spannender.
Als äh als der der Heimrechner und ähm man man darf also gespannt sein äh was da noch so kommen wird, ja.
Ja, damit sie mal im Wesentlichen eigentlich äh durch mit der Nachrichtenlage. Immerhin ist mal wieder was passiert. Letzte Woche war ja nicht so viel los, deswegen haben wir mal ein bisschen die Füße aufs Sofa gelegt.
In der Zwischenzeit haben sich dann äh Kollegen ein bisschen erzirnt und äh sich äh die Wut von der Liebe geschrieben.
Ja, also genau, so das Thema ist jetzt wir haben ja letzte Mal schon, das wollten wir vielleicht nur ganz kurz besprechen, wir haben ja letzte Mal Ärger bekommen von einigen Hörern, weil wir so viel über Julio gesprochen haben, das wäre nicht Netzpolitik.
Ja, Senior A Sanchez.
Wie siehst du das? Ich ich würde sagen, das ist äh.
Na gut, ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen so ein Thema, was hier so herein äh äh geerbt wurden jetzt äh in dem Moment, wo es jetzt nur um
ihn und seine Asylproblematik geht, et cetera. Da kann man natürlich lange darüber diskutieren, ob das jetzt eine Dimension hat. Das hat auf jeden Fall eine politische Dimension. Das Ganze ist natürlich,
ursprünglich mal ausgegangen von der generellen Fragestellung, Wiki Leaks und seine Bedeutung in Bezug auf,
Öffentliche Information, Bedeutung des Internets und so weiter. Also ich meine, da ist jetzt ein ein mittelbarer äh Bezug natürlich gegeben. Wir sind jetzt so ein bisschen
glaube ich äh einfach äh auf dem Thema auch hängengeblieben, weil das äh äh diese Story zu verfolgen, das jetzt einfach mal interessant, ja? Also unsere Hörer wollen das.
Unser Herr wollen Rose.
Ja, wir müssen ja auch, müssen ja auch an die Hörer denken. Nein, ich sehe, also ich sehe, ich sehe das, dass das sozusagen
ein abweichendes Andererseits müssen wir jetzt hier auch glaube ich nicht päpstlicher sein, als der Papst, was unsere thematische Ausrichtung betrifft, wir reden halt, worüber wir äh Lust haben, hier und die Leitlinie ist natürlich ganz klar
Politik, aber wir sind ja hier auch nicht DPA.
Also ich meine also ich würd's schon irgendwie in dem Bereich der der Netzpolitik weiterhin so im im weit gefassten Rahm.
Netzpolitische Boulevard.
Netzpolitischer Boulevard, aber es ist so ein es zeigt halt sowas, was für ein Ausmaß dieser
dieser Netzkram irgendwie inzwischen unserer Gesellschaft hat. Ja, ich finde solche Fälle immer recht spannend. Ich meine, ich ich begegne immer noch Leuten, denen ich sage, ja, hier in Netzpolitik oder so. Äh Politik, was ist das denn? Dann sagst du irgendwie so, ja hier, irgendwie Politik und Internet, wie Politik mit Internet zu tun, ne? Und dann natürlich diese ähm.
Überschneidungen, die dann da eben auch stattfinden. Ja, also wisst ihr, es haben jetzt quasi Netz Netz oder politische Akteure aus dem Netz,
Inzwischen diplomatische Krisen ausgelöst und zwar mehrere.
Auf jeden Fall können wir uns eigentlich über unsere Kommentare und äh unsere mitdiskutanten in den Kommentaren nicht beschweren.
Genau das kann ich nicht und das ist ja auch etwas, was ich immer zitiere, seit ich mehr Podcaster als schreibe, habe ich nettere Kommentare.
Bei den Bloggern sieht's nicht so gut aus.
Bei den Bloggern sieht's nicht so gut aus. Ähm Netzpolitik org, ähm die Problematik ist mir ja seit, also als auch dort Schreibender. Ähm ist mir durchaus bekannt, dass Kommentare eigentlich jetzt,
sage ich mal selten also,
Es kommt sehr selten vor, dass ein ein Kommentar unter einen Artikel geschrieben wird, der ähm mich als Autor weiterbringt.
Ich hatte ja irgendwie letzte Folge schon angesprochen, äh wenn Thorsten Kleinst was kommentiert, dann gibt's ist es meistens eine Korrektur und die trifft meistens zu und das ist dann ein Kommentar, der der irgendwie äh,
mich weiterbringen und und auch den Leser weiterbringt, weil er eine eine thematische Ergänzung.
Bietet. Ähm häufig sind's aber natürlich auch Kommentare, die einen dann irgendwie als Person irgendwie angreifen oder so ähm oder die,
relativ dann irgendwie andere Leute angreifen. Das heißt, wenn du irgendwas über die GEMA schreibst, hast du spätestens bei Kommentar drei, hast du dann irgendwie
irgendwie solche Kommentare drunter die keine inhaltliche Ergänzung darstellen.
Und.
Insgesamt haben dann jetzt also nach längerem hin und her überlege und das Thema weiß ich ist hinter den Kulissen bei Netzpolitik Ork schon seit Jahren äh wird das diskutiert. Ähm was macht man.
Mit den Kommentaren, ja, also das die Kommentarspalte bei Netzpolitik org wird nicht im dem Anspruch äh gerecht, den man an ein Diskussionsmedium stellt.
Und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, woran das liegt, beziehungsweise wie man das ändern kann. Mir ähm.
Ist auch nicht bekannt, dass es irgendwo anders so wäre, dass die Kommentarspalte eine besondere Bereicherung wäre.
Also wenn ich bei Spiegel Online, ich meine Spiegel Online Kommentare, kannste, da sind wir bei Netzpolitik Org noch äh im sehr gesunden Bereich, im, im Gegensatz zu oder YouTube-Kommentare, YouTube-Kommentare ist auch super. Ähm.
Aber die Frage stellt sich so diesen.
Der Anspruch, den wir ihm ja in dieses Web zwei Punkt null mit der kommentiererei und so haben, der wird da irgendwie nicht erfüllt. Und das bei Netzpolitik org, was ja so da, sage ich mal, die.
Immer so das Vereinsheim der der Nerd irgendwie so ist, ne?
Und ähm dass das auch eine in der Regel eigentlich eine eine Überdurchschnittlich gebildete und überdurchschnittliche intelligente Leserschaft hat.
Ich meine, das Problem ist ja bei, ich habe das jetzt so im Einzelnen über die Jahre nicht so verfolgt, aber Slash Dot hatte ja auch relativ früh dieses Treuproblem.
Und Slash hat ja schon vor langer, langer, langer Zeit so dieses Voting äh dort eingeführt,
womit quasi die Qualität eines Beitrags äh geratet wird von den anderen,
Lesern und man kann dann selber als Leser.
Für sich einstellen, welche Art von Kommentaren man denn gerne,
ähm sehen möchte und ich habe jetzt die Liste des Rankings da nicht mehr so ganz äh im Kopf, aber da gibt's halt dann so äh Einstufungen wie Insightfull, informativ,
Ja, also wo sozusagen dem dem Kommentar einfach eine gewisse Aussagekraft zugestanden wird von anderen.
Und äh ich weiß, dass ich gar nicht im Einzelnen, wie dieser Algorithmus dort funktioniert, ob man dann selber einen gewissen Status haben muss, um solche äh,
ähm
solche Bewertungen zu vergeben, ja, das fände ich aber auch interessant und äh leider ist das so in diesen Wordpress basierten System ist mir äh kein solches Ratingsystem bekannt, was jetzt das so wie bei Slash Dot macht
Technik aber ist natürlich,
Das ist natürlich schon so, ne? Ja, dann kommt natürlich gleich die Zensurschreierei, ne,
Ähm die finde ich äh Quatsch, weil äh Zensur heißt, dass ich jemanden daran hindere, überhaupt eine Information zu verbreiten. Es gibt ja kein Anrecht da dran, dass das ausgerechnet in meinem Outlet tut.
Ja, also es.
Ich glaube, die Diskussion muss man nicht lange führen und.
Den Rest des Internets.
Genau oder in dem Moment, wo man anderen Leuten überhaupt die Möglichkeit einräumt, quasi auf gleicher Augenhöhe, also mit
der eigentlichen Publikationsleistung verbunden, dem die äh Kommentare direkt darunter stehen, da äh auch äh dazu beizutragen, denke ich, übernimmt man als Kommentierer auch eine gewisse Verantwortung, der dann eben manche nicht
gerecht werden, indem sie das dann eben nutzen, um was weiß ich, äh für Meinungen da äh in die Welt zu posaunen, die nicht unbedingt als Meinung durchgehen.
Das wäre aber dann, da würde ich genau sagen,
oder das wäre meine meine Sorge bei so 'n oder irgendwie die Bewertung der Kommentare, Ansatz, dass natürlich genau die Leute, die irgendwie treu Kommentare schreiben,
Unter Umständen dann eben die Qualität eines Kommentares verwechseln mit der,
Äh Aussage des Kommentares und entsprechend unliebsame Meinungen dann als schlecht. Ähm.
Ja, aber ich, ja, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass du meinst, das das wäre jetzt ein Modell, wo jeder alles bewerten kann.
Ja, also das das geht nicht, da muss man sich natürlich gegen.
Man quasi eine erweiterte Autorenschaft hat, die sich in dem Moment auch um Kommentare kümmert. Das müssen aber jetzt nicht unbedingt Leute sein, die da normalerweise schreiben, sondern es ist schlicht und ergreifend Leute, die man kennt,
und ja, deren Bereitschaft äh äh.
Da mitzuhelfen. Ja, genau. Also ich meine, ich kann da wieder nur ein altes Beispiel ähm bringen, was ich äh häufiger mal hervorkrame.
Als wir seinerzeit äh diese Villa äh gemacht haben, dieses Telefon äh System, wo wir dann auch Leute hatten, die quasi in dieser Audiowelt äh herumgelatscht sind,
und und wir kannten die halt und wussten, dass das die quasi das Ökosystem erhalten wollen, das Ökosystem Villa für ihre Zwecke
Ja, dass die dann eben so mit antitreu äh äh Munition ausgestattet wurden und dann eben so Leute, die da einfach nur rumgerülpst und rumgepupst haben
einfach stumm schalten können, ohne dass sie es selber gemerkt haben. Und äh was eigentlich eine sehr angenehme,
Das hat einfach sofort funktioniert, ja? Das, das, das, das Problem war einfach sofort weg. Jetzt beim Blog nicht ganz so einfach, aber in dem Moment, wo man weiß, okay, es gibt hier zehn, zwanzig, dreißig, ich meine, die die potentielle Liste von Leuten, die so eine
Moderationsleistung durchführen könnten. Ja, die regelmäßige Leser sind, et cetera, ist halt.
Sicherlich nicht klein bei Netzpolitik org. Wie groß jetzt würde ich die Bereitschaft ist, kann ich nicht quantifizieren, genau, die Zahlen nicht. Ich sage nur, meine Vermutung ist,
dass es sowas schon gibt. Ich kenne jetzt keine technischen Lösungen, kein Plug-in oder sowas, was man anschalten kann, aber das kann man sich ja zur Not auch äh entwickeln, kurz gesagt, äh es gibt halt Leute, die sind angemeldet, die sind quasi dem System gegenüber bekannt und die können dann eben,
Freischaltung auch äh machen, ja? Also denen traut man das quasi auch zu, aber eben auch so eine Einstufung.
Also die die Hoffnung wäre eben die die.
Also das wäre das wäre der eine Ansatz, äh wie wird, wie wird man die Spinner los, ja? Und dann wäre natürlich noch die die zweite Hoffnung dieser.
Das wird wahrscheinlich dann so ein sekundärer Effekt, der dann eintreten wird, dass dann auch wieder mehr Leute dort überhaupt mal was Vernünftiges sagen, ne, also äh dass man da vernünftige eine vernünftige Debattenkultur entwickelt oder so.
Genau. Und der Quatsch bleibt dann im Prinzip noch da, ist aber einfach nicht sichtbar. Steigt einfach nicht nach oben. Und es ist eigentlich eine natürlicher Umgang äh mit mit so etwas, wie ich finde.
Gut, das ändert nichts an der Tatsache, dass ja offensichtlich die Bereitschaft da produktiv mitzuwirken, auch Schaden genommen hat, aber das kann eben auch damit zu tun haben. Ich meine, wer äh ich hatte auch schon,
Kommentar,
beizusteuern, weil da war jetzt was ja Internet,
und äh habe das dann aber auch gelassen, weil ich gar keine Lust habe in so einem Morast da äh äh,
wo dann tausend Leute wieder mit weißt du auch diesen Kommentar wieder auseinandernehmen. Also wenn ich nicht weiß, dass das,
auch von Leuten, die nachdenken können, auch aufgenommen wird und gegebenenfalls auch abgesegnet wird. Und da lasse ich das dann lieber.
Obwohl ich auch gerne kommentiere, muss ich sagen.
Ja, ich, also diese die Kommentarsachen, ich habe da wirklich inzwischen ein ähm
Verhältnis zu, also äh wie ja vielleicht viele auch wissen, habe ich mal zum siebenundzwanzig C drei äh ein kleines äh Block, Kommentarding gebastelt, wo man
Block kommentieren kann. Ähm und das erfreut sich also äh in den Statistiken, die ich da lese, enormer Beliebtheit und hat.
Also das Reh FIFA.
Genau, das äh findet man unter Blog Punkt Refe DE. Äh.
Da kann man eben, ja, Kommentare zu schreiben, die Sache war natürlich, irgendwie immer, FIFA hatte nie Kommentare und man konnte sich irgendwie die Düster, die Dunkelheit vorstellen, die, äh, die sich,
da entfalten würde und die wollte ich dann ganz gerne mal sehen zu meiner eigenen Belustigung und ähm habe dann äh kurz was gebaut,
wo man eben viel fürs Block kommentieren kann. Und das war eigentlich so als kleiner kleiner Scherz gedacht und ich wollte das eigentlich auch nicht besonders lange online lassen
weil ich damit recht gerechnet habe, dass ich damit relativ schnell irgendwie eine Abmahnung bekomme, weil,
ich überhaupt nicht die da irgendwie eine Kommentarkontrolle oder so äh leisten kann. Das Ding hat jetzt irgendwie in anderthalb Jahren äh an die fünfundsechzigtausend Kommentare bekommen.
Das ist halb so viel wie Netzpolitik org in sieben Jahren bekommen hat. Ja, also das ist ähm also das Ding, das Ding wird
Die kommentieren da, wie die Wilden durcheinander
Und ich habe, kann das überhaupt nicht leisten, das alles zu lesen. Deswegen schreibe ich auch ins Impressum. Ich lese das hier nicht äh äh ich habe damit nix zu tun
und wenn irgendwann hier irgendwo Scheiße steht, dann sagt mir Bescheid, dann dann lösche ich. Aber ich habe noch nicht mal einen Mechanismus, um da ich muss dann in die Datenbank reingehen, ja. Ähm.
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass da eine besonders hohe äh hohes Niveau an Diskussionen äh äh erreicht wird. Also,
eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Ich frage mich nur, was die Leute äh da hin zieht, ja, also die Leute sind völlig begeistert von dem Ding und und schreiben da irgendwie ihren Kram drunter. Und ich habe also,
Ich habe da natürlich absichtlich keine äh Treukontrollmechanismen, weil,
Das einzige, was dein Citro-Kontrollmechanismus wäre, vielleicht eine Api für andere Blogs ähm zu sehen, wer schon mal da kommentiert hat und die halt woanders auf jeden Fall schon mal direkt in Spam zu gehen. Ähm.
Entschuldigung, liebe liebe Kommentatoren bei Refe, aber ähm ich bin schon ganz froh, dass ihr, dass ich euch da binden kann.
Ciao.
Jetzt habe ich übrigens zum ersten Mal äh zugegeben, was der die zweite Motivation bei Refe war.
Ja, ich, ja, also ich meine, ich bin ja generell für offene Kommunikation,
zu haben so, also ich finde auch, also ich will unbedingt Kommentare haben zu dem, was ich mache, also mir ist das wichtig, ich kann Leute, die das mit dem Argument, ich habe keinen Bock auf den Scheiß, das kann ich zwar nachvollziehen, warum sie der Meinung sind, aber ich,
dieselben Schlüsse für mich so nicht ziehen. Ähm der Trollfaktor ist auch relativ gering. Ich habe das ein paar Mal gehabt, dass da mal auch einer irgendwie wirre daher kam
ähm meistens bedenke ich, dass irgendwie äh entweder einfach mit Ignoranz, wenn's wirklich zu blöd ist oder ähm.
Ja oder schreibt da einfach ganz neutral kurz was dazu und dann ist auch aus den Augen aus dem Sinn, ne.
Ja, also.
Darf sich auch nicht so aufregen, ne? Ich meine, beim Markus ist es.
Na ja, ich meine, Richter sich da, er regt sich, glaube ich, nicht so. Also der Artikel war auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, etwas heißer gekocht, als er ihn als seinen
Als sein Blut in dem Moment, als er ihn geschrieben hat, so. Also ähm er hat das ja jetzt wirklich viele Jahre auch mit sehr stuischer Gelassenheit
durchgezogen, während ich schon relativ früh angefangen habe selbst die Kommentare auf meine eigenen Artikel nicht mehr zu lesen. Ja, also ich habe dann diese E-Mail Benachrichtigung irgendwie nach der F null geworfen und,
damit war das Thema erledigt. Ich habe das nicht angeguckt und wenn irgendwas richtig, wenn irgendwas dabei war, was meiner Aufmerksamkeit bedurfte, dann wurde ich schon früher oder später darauf hingewiesen. Ähm.
Ich meine, wenn man, wenn man den Kommentaren oder auch sonst wo äh äh im Netz so mit Schmutz beworfen wird, das wirkt natürlich oder kann schon sehr deportivierend wirken und es hat auch sehr viel äh mit dem eigenen Selbstwertgefühl zu tun, wie man dem,
begegnet.
Das ist zum Beispiel also.
Man da sozusagen noch auf Zuspruch hofft oder setzt und und und dann aber äh merkt, dass es da irgendwie so ein so ein Mob äh äh gibt, der einem aus nicht nachvollziehbaren Gründen da äh an die Wäsche will,
Das kann einen schon schnell äh abtörnen und dann auch vertreiben.
Das ist absolut ähm das ist absolut richtig und es ist auch ein wirklich ein ein starker Effekt,
Spannend ist das, wenn du so einen Artikel schreibst und hast von mir aus ähm oder jetzt eine so
Sagen wir mal den, den lesen irgendwie zehntausend, fuffzehntausend Leute. Du siehst irgendwie in den in den in den Statistiken ganz normale Artikel, keine besondere Aufmerksamkeit. Fünfzehntausend Leute haben sich den angeguckt. Und da drunter hast du
sechzig Kommentare von sagen wir mal vierzig verschiedenen Personen oder so, ja? Ähm,
Unter den vierzig Personen äh befinden sich zwei, die irgendwie außer sich sind, weil weil das die größte faschistische Ding ist, was sie an diesem Tag im Internet gesehen haben, ja. Ähm.
Es ist als als Empfänger dieser Kommentare enorm schwer, das trotzdem in dieses Verhältnis zu setzen, zu sehen, da sind äh drei Leute von,
Fünfzehntausend, die irgendwie Anstoß daran nehmen, weil das ist natürlich das einzige Feedback, was du bekommst,
über deinen Artikel. Es sei denn, der hat irgendwie schlicht so ein, das sind aber dann die, die halt vierzigtausend äh Leser empfangen, wo dann auf Twitter irgendwie viele sagen, Lesebefehl oder so. Das ist natürlich, das ist auch immer Feedback für den
für den Autor, ne? Also dieses.
Also dieses dieses überhaupt dieses Verhältnis zwischen mir gefällt es eigentlich auch gar nicht so bei den Blogs, dieses Verhältnis zwischen äh da oben ist der Artikel, da unten drunter ist die wie viel für das nennt, die Treugrube.
Ähm die können der Pöbel kann da unten spielen und ich stehe aber erhaben darüber oben drüber, ne. Äh ich mir wär's eigentlich viel lieber, viel mehr Track Bags zu bekommen.
Wobei Trapex natürlich den Nachteil haben, wenn wenn die Leute dann da auf einen losgehen, dann haste, kannst du das halt nicht löschen, ne? Ähm.
Ja, also interessant auf jeden Fall, Ende vom Lied, äh nachdem Netz Politik Org dann mit diesem mit diesem Artikel, Kommentare schließen, Fragezeichen
Ein sehr große, sehr große Aufmerksamkeit erlangt hat, folgte dann der ähm,
Artikel, in dem äh komme mit dem äh Kommentar Kultur neu entwickeln, in dem dann eben um äh Vorschläge und,
technische Lösungs äh Möglichkeiten gebeten wurde, äh.
Kommentarkultur irgendwie zu mehr Nützlichkeit zu verhelfen.
Ich habe hier gerade nochmal dieses ähm Kommentarsystem von Slash Dot angeschaut, was ich wirklich, wirklich cool finde,
Ähm das ist die Kategorien, in die äh die Sachen da ein äh sortiert werden, ist Insidefull,
Also im Sinne von, hier hat jemand Einblick und so und äh trägt substantiell dazu bei, dann in Formetiv sozusagen so.
Reicht vielleicht nicht diesen ganzen, diesen gleichen Charakter von jemand hat Einblick, aber der Kommentar trägt sozusagen eine Information mit, ja,
Dann gibt's noch irgendwie interessing und funny.
Ist ja auch interessant finde. Also man kann sich zumindest auch auf die lustigen Kommentare äh konzentrieren. Dann kann man eben für jede Kategorie mit so einem kleinen Slider auch noch sagen, welche man irgendwie äh jetzt in voller Menge angezeigt bekommt davon, welche,
äh nur in abgekürzter Form, ja und welche aus wie viele davon jetzt auch ausgeblendet werden. Also ist schon,
Schon ein sehr interessantes äh System und man kann dann eben, wenn man sich da entsprechend einloggt auch seine ähm Prisetts einstellen et cetera.
Und du du die haben so ein Karma-System.
Genau.
Sehe ich grade.
Ja ja.
Können wir uns ja nochmal anschauen und vielleicht das Thema äh später nochmal aufgreifen. Ich denke, das ist äh durchaus etwas, wo es sich lohnt, nochmal ein bisschen mehr zu forschen.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber das das Problem ist irgendwie da und äh ich habe da auch,
abschließend sagen, ich habe da schon mehrfach Vorträge auch drüber gehalten, dass ich irgendwie persönlichen im Moment noch so ein bisschen von dem Web zwei Punkt null enttäuscht bin
So dieser, der, der, der große Revolutionäre äh Effekt, auch wenn wir überall tolle, tolle Auswüchse sehen, aber so der
das volle Potential äh scheint irgendwie noch nicht so ganz äh äh erreicht worden zu sein.
Weil das Publishing einfach noch nicht einfach genug ist. Das ist ja auch ein Podcasting, nicht anders und das ist eigentlich beim Bloggen auch nicht anders. Also ich denke, alles das, was wir bisher als einfach angesehen haben, das äh finden dieses Prädikat eigentlich noch nicht. Wird sich zeigen.
In diesem Sinne tun wir, glaube ich, die Sendung jetzt auch zum Abschluss bringen oder hast du noch was äh äh Wichtiges beizutragen?
Nee, äh sowieso nicht,
Merkt man ja glaube ich in den letzten zehn Minuten.
Na gut, das war jetzt sozusagen nochmal ein äh kleiner Anhang als Ausgleich für die äh verlorene Folge von der letzten Woche und wir sehen uns dann wieder nächste Woche. Ne, und äh da halten sie jetzt noch etwas mit leiser Musik. Bis bald.